[Music]
what's up Wolfgang it's only been a day
since Marvel has given us a new trailer
but here they are again with another new
one they're so kind
this is a legacy trailer so they show
some clips from the past but if you pay
attention and watch super closely you
can see some new scenes and as always if
you want to stay up to date on the
latest with Avengers infinity war go
ahead and subscribe to my channel
your mother approves it just mother know
you wear as her drapes
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people
to see if we could become something more
someone they needed us we can fight the
battles
the end is near Avengers infinity so the
first new scene is easy to catch it's
actually a few second song which is
Stannis with the Black Order but towards
the end did you catch all those scenes
that are like point zero 1 of a second
long if you didn't don't worry we got
you covered we'll show them to you
the first new scene of the trailer is
stano's surrounded by his Black Order
with his fist raised in the air with the
Infinity Gauntlet on it and in the
background is just destruction if you
notice there's purple all around and it
seems like it's energy that's kind of
disappearing but the next scene right
after this is just of the Infinity
Gauntlet in the air and the power stone
is highlighted
looks like danos closes his hand and
uses the power of the power stone to
destroy wherever he's mad there's either
one of two places where he's at right
now the first place he could be is on
zan dart where he's getting the power
stone from the Nova Corps but seeing as
he already has two Infinity stones it's
most likely that he already went to
Xander and retrieved the power stone so
he's most likely on the ship that Thor
and the rest of Asgard is on so these
next few scenes are like 1/10 of a
second long so let's freeze frame them
and talk about them for a bit ok this
seemed Warmachine up in the air and will
connect going hey I'm on Thanos's army
it looks like they just broke through
the force field I'm more machines trying
to keep him back it also looks like war
machine has some new technology on his
suit I'm guessing that this is the same
nanotechnology that Iron Man will have
on his suit either way he's bringing
some big guns to the party
I don't see how that's a party next new
scene
star-lord holding his gun up in what
looks like the collectors place you can
see in the background there's a case
with something in it which is what the
collector does when he collects things
you can also note that things are on
fire in the background so it's safe to
say that Thanos has come in search of
the reality stone and it looks like
star-lord got there right after Thinnes
finished it also looks like he's kind of
hiding himself and it makes sense
because he's probably with Gamora
and Gamora knows who Tanis is Gamora
being the adopted daughter of Thanos
knows how powerful he is and knows that
they don't stand any chance but probably
tells them to lay low until Thanos
leaves next new scene and again you'd
have to be watching really closely to
see it it's Shuri examining the mine
stone that's in visions forehead I've
said this in previous videos but what
Conda is the most technologically
advanced country in the MCU and we know
the Avengers take vision to Wakanda so
they can protect him knowing the threat
that Thanos is going to come for the
mind stone they are most likely figuring
out a way how they can get the mind
stone out of visions for head while also
keeping him alive does this scene
increase visions odds of surviving
Avengers infinity war I guess we'll have
to see this next new scene is Proxima
midnight and the Scarlet Witch
it seems like Proxima midnight is
obviously trying to kill the Scarlet
Witch here but the Scarlet Witch using
her magic is resisting Proxima midnight
Proxima midnight is the most skilled
fighter of Thanos's Black Order or
children of fan OHS which is what
they're calling them in the movie and
she has superhuman strength so you can
see the confusion on her face as Scarlet
Witch resists her okay the last new
scene of this trailer could contain some
spoilers so if you've made it this far
and haven't turned away you may want to
consider now if you don't want to know
anything about Avengers infinity war
this scene is Ironman holding back
star-lord judging by the looks of it
they are on Titan and it looks like
star-lord is just screaming at the top
of his lungs I can kind of only think of
one reason why this scene would take
place
Thanos probably takes Gamora the Maurya
Stannis's adopted daughter and he is
mentioned before that she is his
favorite daughter when he sees her again
for the first time
more than likely be pretty upset so I
won't be surprised if when he sees her
on Titan he just grabs her and takes her
away so that's it for all the new scenes
in this trailer and less some were even
faster than the ones in it and and one
over our heads and we missed it did you
guys catch these scenes the first time
around and what do you guys think of
them and what do you think is happening
in them let me know in the comments
below and be sure to give this video a
like and please don't leave me lonely
and subscribe to my channel thank you so
much for watching
woof woof